we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we had a
caller who had a thought about flat
earthers let's take a listen to what
they had to say david like my name is
david stone I live in Berkshire County I
was I've been watching these SpaceX
launches YouTube once in a while and I
love your interviews you have to get any
some of these latter you know because I
think this is like something the biggest
joke so my soul must have started this
is like a joke let's see if we can
convince X number of people that the
earth is flat and he's flat earthers are
just all over the place on these on
these videos these live feeds and the
rocket launches for SpaceX or whatnot
yeah I actually don't know how much
value there would be to interviewing
flat earthers like was I I interview
extremists all the time and I'm
interested in how they they became
extremists and I think that there's
something interesting there but what are
we gonna do with a flat earth or in an
interview I don't know that it would be
that interesting like what's your
instinct I feel like it might be
interesting just to see if they'll give
you their sources as to why they think
the earth is flat yeah just to
understand where these ideas come from I
just feel like with any idea that I kind
of consider crazy I do feel like it
helps to sit down and just be like okay
where are you coming from why do you
think this because some people just
aren't all that bright so if you find
out that they think this because when
they walk from here to stop and shop
it's flat right okay we might be able to
deal with that more quickly yeah I don't
know and what do you think Pat about
what the caller said that maybe for some
people it's a joke like they're not
serious about it I think that a lot of
that earthers are totally definitely
serious flat earthers i want to bring
one on to the program because i think
there are so many things there like
concrete evidence that the world is
round and i want to see how they are
presented with that information yeah and
also i'd like to know where the edge of
the earth is like where you're gonna
fall off if earth is indeed brown why no
one has fallen i'm gonna find that out a
fair question and i think i think that
that one i think it would be a perfect
interview for me to use my now frequent
a question of what would it take to
change your mind which now i'm parodied
because i use that very often with
people who
just believe very odd things I say what
would change your mind is there anything
that if I presented to you would change
your mind and the answers are often odd
I guess to say the least so it's it's an
opportunity send me your thoughts if
you're interested in me interviewing a
flat earther if so how would we find one
I guess the guy with the jetpack or
whatever might be a good candidate we've
got a great bonus show today we will
talk to Jen briny about her podcast
congressional dish we will talk about
buzz aldrin will talk about video
recording our word our dreams as well
will speak to you then